[Music]
so yeah like here one I'm Kenneth I'm
originally from Copenhagen Denmark I
recently took a little rocket or plane
and moved to Canada and I work for this
tiny little company called Microsoft and
what I do at Microsoft is really all
about dev tools so I'm a program manager
so that means I do product strategy I do
a lot of prototyping working closely
with my engineers to basically figure
out like what the diff tools of the
future should be and I think personally
I spent the past many years in the
community doing a lot of diff tools kind
of hacking and then this year joined
Microsoft to do it as a full-time paid
job I think we as developers is like we
really care about the tools we use each
and every day so I'm basically here to
talk about how we think about the future
for furtive tools and how we think about
we can maybe do things a bit in a
different way but first I would like to
quite a bit of context I am on the web
platform and and how we need to think
about dev tools and going forward so I
think it's pretty clear for all of us
that we all real big developer Joel
using javascript and but the big
platform has changed quite significantly
over the past I would say five years
like when I started building from the
web it was all about documents doing
simple text documents and that was
basically like that's why we have
hypertext markup language to do a
scientific report we had a CSS we would
style the documents but if you actually
look at like how the majority of us are
using the platform and the browser today
is all about applications this is just
animated gave her like Netflix that
majority of America is used in each and
every day and which actually quite a
complicated application when you think
about it and even if you look at the
devices we're using each and every day
they've also changed and I remember like
the good old workstation Mac or like the
the good old laptop I had plenty of
these with the noble guys over the years
so like if you look at the devices were
using today they at least from Microsoft
they look quite a bit different we have
like service to studios all about
charged surface where services if used a
macbook if you're the ipad the devices
has changed quite fundamentally from
being this workstation kind of thing to
something thats a bit more mobile and
and really when we talk about the what
devices people are using to browse the
web it's really about mobile devices and
like today mobile phones and then large
phones tablets kind of thing comes in a
lot of different sizes and that's been a
lot of stuff happening in terms of i
remember my good old naka 3210 that way
i could play snake to like my my iphone
7 i'm using today right so our mobile
devices has changed quite a bit too and
even the browser's all of us are using
every day our customers using every day
has changed like today we have like
chrome as a market leader we actually
have safari a hat with if we include
like a iPads as a pretty significant
disk top market share because the ipass
are grown so big today and and then we
have like if you look at our market
share like for Microsoft our itch marga
chair still growing we're still trying
to kill the remaining bits of IE but one
day I'm sure we will succeed and so like
that this desktop landscape has changed
quite a bit and I just want to touch
upon like I'm i'm on the edge devtools
team and as a part of a new our effort
of I've actually reinvesting in the web
then we decided to kill I we doing edge
and that was basically because what
Microsoft did previously was basically
just Mike dropping out of the the stage
after doing re 6 because there was an
awesome browser at least back then and
but we're basically reinventing or
trying to reinvent a our approach to how
we build for the web and and another
interesting thing we look alike our
devices has changed our browsers we use
each every day has changed but also
internet adoption has changed and like
now I know now we're in Singapore but
but when I show this and in the Western
world people are amazed there are more
people living inside the circle and then
outside of it let's just so show
something
about how the next billion will go
online or what markets are that are
relevant and what kind of devices people
use in when they go online and we need
to think about this when we build our
websites when we optimize our user
experiences but also when we build our
tools and it's just another interesting
fact that I think many people tend to
forget it's like that's more people
online in China then there's population
in Europe it's a mind-boggling number
when you think of it but people forget
and to me that's interesting because it
shows a lot of opportunity yeah but it's
also tells me that we maybe need to
rethink our approach to 225 tools and I
just want to code Bennett Evans here
it's like saying mobile Internet is the
same as saying color TV it's kind of
implied when you watch TV today that is
in color and kind of when you go online
today it's kind of implied that you do
it from your mobile phone or you do it
for from a wearable like this mobile
thing is just the way we do things and
and when we think about mobile the
mobile landscape has also changed quite
a bit and actually if we look alike over
market shares you see browsers more
popular than sapphire mobile that's
almost eighteen percent of the global
market share we are still seeing a
significant chunk of Android the stock
android browser on all the android
phones we're seeing new browsers like
the purple one that is sam some internet
growing the triple-digit market shares
every every month because it's now the
new default browser on samsung devices
so we're basic seeing a whole shift here
from traditional browsers to new players
that are entering the market we're also
seeing players like grave and Yandex
actually gaining pretty good market
shares so the more interesting thing is
we responded engineers of web developers
what we care about is like the engine We
Need to Talk it and we're seeing like
you you three engine actually being
larger than safari but most of us don't
know how you you see browsers working on
the inside because it's a proprietary
lipid fork no one has access to it and
that's interesting and then we have like
the good old players like Babe kid we
have playing HTML our engine we have
cake
but we also see like new browsers coming
around like brave that is just using
whatever engine that is available on the
underlying platform so when you use
brave on Windows is right now as an
electron app if you use it on your
iPhone is using lip kit if using on all
Android device it's using Android
browser so kind of switching the
underlying engine when it's relevant and
to me that's interesting because this
shows that that the web world and we
have gained so much compatibility that
just doing the engine itself it's the
longer competitive advantage this also
changes our perspective when we build
stuff for the web and then we are seeing
all of this the this whole trend of the
progressive web and we like my bed here
is that in a few years you introduces
and you as the developer won't know that
you're using a browser anymore because
what we are already seeing on mobile
platforms is the bit being embedded
inside native we see that on Android
with chrome custom tabs as the Pinterest
app that can just embed like an advanced
VIP you inside the native shell we're
seeing it on iOS chew with Safari view
controllers so we've seen this full
emergence of like native platforms and
the web melding together in this
combined experience and on a desktop
we're seeing the bib used as a runtime
too so we see that in slag that she's an
electron app at Microsoft we should we
shall studio code our open source editor
it's just a bit app chip inside electron
and so we're basically seeing the VIP
being being merged into all of the
different categories of apps we use from
our mobile phones to all desktops and
that's really exciting because that
means we can ship more as with
developers and and then we have this
whole progressive web app movement where
we're suddenly a you can go to a ul and
the website can be promoted to your home
screen and and live outside of the
regular browser you are in the browser
Chrome which I find really interesting
and that's some of the thing is that it
would be a Microsoft spending a lot of
time looking at so right now we have
service worker fetch cash push bit
manifest all in development in edge and
the reason for this is because we want
to bring the progressive bit to the
desktop and we have still have quite a
significant chunk of users using a
our platforms and specially using
desktops and right now we find it
relatively that you have to install an
electron app and it's a kind of a clunky
experience what if the desktop
experience could just be you go to
Netflix and certainly it's on your
desktop the terms a lot of interesting
questions because what is a home screen
around this top how does all these
things work what if you open up the
desktop browser and you go to Netflix
should open up the PVA you have on your
desktop or should you stay inside the
browser that's a lot of interesting
challenges with that will be working
hard and trying to crack this not
because we think that's the way and that
is the future for the web and another
interesting thing when we look at all
this changed new devices new platforms
do rendering engines we also seen this
next paradigm shift that is going to
happen it's basically bit assembly so
all major browser vendors are shipping
at least an experimental implementation
of live assembly that basically allows
any native developer to take their C++
code compile it by a.m script not
something that can generate bassam code
and run it inside the browser that is
being that vapor simply code bassam code
is being run by the JavaScript engine
and then ultimately is being rendered by
a bit GL and this it like it's an
interesting challenge a lot of us whip
developers because here there's no HTML
or JavaScript involved anymore it's just
your native game the Sun can run in the
browser and kind of my point here is
that the front-end role is being
redefined these years like a lot of us
we care about HTML and JavaScript but as
the VIP and native ameri and we're
trying to bring more advanced
capabilities into the platform front end
is being redefined and a good example of
this is for example my my android watch
that can show push notifications so I
can get a push notification from chrome
running in a service worker that it was
excavated but by a few lines of
JavaScript and the question I'm asking
myself are you a front-end developer if
you write JavaScript in a service worker
to show push notification that is
rendered natively no HTML know CSS on
your watch I your front-end developer
because you just wrote a back at an
integration right and i think that's
that's going to be an interesting
challenge for us
when we think tooling but also we think
our identity because JavaScript
emergencies this might not be as
relevant in the future as you think and
kind of my job at Microsoft is to think
about all these things and and try to
make sense of it and say so how does
devtools fit into all this and and kind
of when I look at like the dev tools we
are shipping today they all were we
similar if we look at like and if you
look at the dev tools we shipping we
ship an edge like Google shipping chrome
and they're all kind of the same kind of
had the same functionality and my point
here is that I think our industry has a
dev tools dogma we kind of had this
preconception and a diff tool is
something that is installed as a patio
desktop browser so it has to be docked
at the bottom of your screen it has to
have like a dominicks lower script tab
maybe a network tool and then is a divot
tool and I'm really asking myself like
is this really can we do better here
because if I look at AG mark what my
team did back in the good old days like
2007 I developer toolbar yay and and I
look alike the tools we're shipping
today they're quite alike the Dom
Explorer you can see like some some
style but technically is kind of the
same tool and if I look alike what
chrome is shipping it's kind of the same
from each tip tools they they have the
same kind of thing like network sources
and like I'm really asking myself in a
world where the web is running outside
of the browser running on a new range of
devices is this really the best we can
do when we think about the whole
development experience and because if
you try to break down like the tools
that all of us shipping today modern div
to the basic a collection of tools it's
a mini ide that has a dom explorer
console debugger network tool
performance profiler maybe has some
memory profiling has some emulation
features it's actually really
complicated set of tools that all
browsers are shipping and yet again they
are like at the bottom of our screens
they're basically in a fraction of our
of our screens and we use them when we
are debugging so we could sit in our
editor we open our dev tools which debug
something and then we switch back to our
authoring context
and basically if you think about this is
what we do all day long which have
between debugging and authoring
debugging and watering and I'm just
trying to like is this really optimal
when we actually think of it because if
i look at the wire workflow like it's
completely broken because our authoring
tools is not the same as our debugging
tools and if i actually look alike the
workflow then this is still a typical
development workflow we open your editor
or your browser you navigate your page
you'll find the file you editor you make
a change you go back to your browser
refresh the page you open the dev tool
you go to the scripts tap you find the
same value just edit it you go to the
Edit line you set your break point you
debug you figure out what's wrong you go
back to your edit so you make a change
step back to to the browser and then you
repeat this all day long unless you have
installed like I guess Saudi enough all
the tools that are running in like five
different command lines and refreshing a
lot of things for you but this is still
the de facto way that you're building
for the web this was fine when the web
was just about the scientific documents
but when we're building applications is
this really good enough and the funny
thing here is like when I talk to
developers and I developers don't
realize that this is a problem they
don't realize that we can do better as
an industry and I call this the bib
develop of Stockholm Syndrome that we
think is perfectly all right and it's
perfectly okay the way we both for the
web and I think I really think with an
industry we can do better add just a few
thoughts here like if you take a step
back and look at our tools that all of
us using every day why do I have to
learn a new diff tool for each browser
why is it given in 2016 why do I have to
use different tools which in autumn and
debugging why is that still a thing why
is my edits a bit more integrated with
Mario browsers and like why addicts will
still bundle with our disturb browsers
it's not like you can open a iphone app
and open motive to land your iPhone or
on your iPad why is diff tool still this
thing we consider mandatory power of the
browser and if you look at it that's
basically this massive disconnect
between and the authoring side and the
debugging side and there's some of the
things like weird Microsoft over the
past months
and some time trying to figure out if we
can do better and because the way we
view about the tools that we think that
the diff tools and editors are basically
complimentary to each other they
shouldn't replace each other but they
should have a way to work together
somehow ahem plus basically what we've
been spending a little time and trying
to basically connect the two walls and
having a more integrated experience when
you're building for the web because it's
too goddamn complicated to build for the
web these days and so what if the
workflow was more like you open your
editor it will be your file you make a
change inside your editor you open your
browser you set a breakpoint inside your
editor you debug it from your editor you
make a change and you just see the
browser update what if you get this cut
the same experience where you're not
forced to use a lot of different tools
so actually back in March we ship like
was something we call vias code chrome
debugger and basically what you're
seeing here is basically animated gif of
vs cote bug in chrome and so you can
basically just say press the debug
button and then vs code connects to to
to chrome and you can set your break
point straight from your editor no need
to leave the editor where you're a
co-author and write the code so this was
like a first experiment we did and I
should turned out that this is quite
popular because this is like the most
public extension we have for Felicia
pieces to decode these days because
people love this integrated experience
so we thought hey like we have our own
proud of what can we do here and so a
few months later we did a blog post or I
did about Poe story announce that we are
now integrated edge with sublime text
and visual studio code because
developers kind of wanted the same
integrated experience and the way we did
this was kind of in in a new i would say
nun microsoft way because we released a
component called the HD Gnostics adapter
and that is basically the protocol
adapter that enables a third-party tools
to interface with edge but instead of
inventing yet another API a proprietary
API and then we did that because if you
look at like modern dev tools they're
both upon something called remote
debugging protocols and tools like
Visual Studio code or chrome tip school
so any other tool were already
integrating with the chrome a bargain
protocol and so we just wrote an adapter
for edge to implement the same API so
that way then we could enable our
existing debuggers for visual studio
Visual Studio code and other two
we'll just work with H out of the box
and kind of the point I want to get
through here that we do support an open
ecosystem web browser and torn vendors
can work together we don't want to like
in enable this closed ecosystem in this
closed world where we try to force you
to use one particular product we want to
enable as many tools working with our
our platform and another interesting
thing here in happened recently
devastating an effort by google is
google committed a new project called v8
inspector to note and that basically
means that node now has embraced the
same a chrome debugging protocol so you
can use chrome dev tools you can use
Visual Studio code to debug node because
it's the same API and this opens up some
really interesting possibilities that
hasn't been possible before because by
having the same API for both the line
side and the back end side of the server
side that means we can actually have
simultaneous debugging and I call this
like the knee ivana of debugging because
that basically means you can keep up
both parts of your application if your
full stack developer as many of us are
today and so I just want to show a quick
demo on how how that actually works so
what I have open here switches to decode
it's the text biggest big enough to the
zoom in ok I didn't hear any or anything
so I think it's ok so basically what I
have here is a visa to decode have a
little note abusing express what you
guys can see here is I serve my my
bundle da housecat allocation with
browserify so it's was bundling my full
application and generating a source map
and and my console application is just
an angular app it can basically view
like a time zone I can see what time it
is in Vancouver and what is in Singapore
and that's about it but the cool thing
here is like what I now can do is that
again just go to the debug mode in visit
to the code and press debug and what
your then seeing is like now I'm avid
the debugger enabled so if i go to my
server side code here i can set a
breakpoint always set it so if i refresh
the page
what you're seeing here is that I'm now
debugging my note code I can step debug
and continue if I go down here I have
the full call stack or what's going on
you know back in time and I going to say
continue that's that's like cool because
then you have visual visual debugging if
a node but one of the things that we
just released and that's a part of like
at the insider build officials to decode
that's why the icon down here is green
is that we have a support for move to
target debugging so what I can do while
my my my debug has now attached to note
is that I can actually just select
chrome up here if I press a debug again
what you're seeing is that I have
another instance of chrome running I'm
now hitting the same server side break
point because the page is loading and
then my avocation is open but now i can
do is that i can just open up my client
side code so i can time to go to a
controller here let's just browse a bit
around on add new click i want to set a
breakpoint i was to see what happens
here is that what you're seeing is like
chrome is now being tossed because
support from Visual Studio code and I
can do step debugging of what's
happening in my client side code and
what you see here is basically you have
like both threads because the our debug
is connected to both parts of your
application and you can basically just
continue to have a continuous debugging
experience across run times and also
across stacks I think this is like the
first step we're taking on bringing a
more simple workflow to your development
workflow because you why would you knew
why would you use a different tool and
when you can just use the same
experience regardless what you need to
debug and kind of the point here that
this is just node and chrome our
architecture of Visual Studio code
allows you to debug edge with you and
would you go back end because we have
debuggers available for that so we can
provide this consistent experience
across your stack you could imagine
you're hitting an API that is running on
your staging server you could just
configure the debugger to connect a tool
richer to your staging server wish I
find really really cool so another thing
we did was basically we thought okay if
the web is all about mobile devices why
don't we just enable
on iOS so we did the same experience and
while you can debug your iOS device when
we should suit your coat same same
intimate experience but the key thing
here is that this was actually the first
time if your Windows you could debug iOS
from your Windows machine before we
release this you could you had to go out
and buy a mac or mac mini just a debug
your iOS device that's no longer needed
and it's the same concept again we used
our same debugger we use the same API
and then we use a protocol adapter to
enable iOS devices to work with our
stuff and a thing i want to touch upon
here it's like when we think about it
it's like now we have like a more
integrated web development workflow
where we can try to avoid a lot of
different tools as a part of our stack
but why is the web one of the few
platforms also bundles a full
development environment with the runtime
i can if i do an android app but do a
native c++ ever my desktop there's no
full ID included as a part of my
application it's not a part that the
user can hit like f12 and suddenly they
see a magic editor right because if you
look at what what induces are
experiencing normal VIP users are
confused this is a screenshot of a
confused user talks about like child
abuse and like it's really being it
feeling confused and the point of this
is because of this is because there's a
warning witnessing here force all of his
children to be wrapped in a block and
like it makes sense likes toolbox for
development contains an inline span
child what the heck is that right and
like imagine that the do of regular whip
used and you just by mistake press
inspect element open this then like
cyber attack what's going on here right
this is really crazy and the thing is
like this is Firefox this is from our
backtrack and edge like normal BIP users
don't know what inspect element is here
there's a person that has played a
facebook game a suddenly clicked inspect
element and now the devtools been open
for three days
like they don't know what's going on
right which is which is kind of scary
because to us as developers is the most
natural thing in the world and if you
open up chrome devtools and you go to
Facebook and Google property your basic
seeing the same that normal dip users
are hacking themselves so Facebook is
forced to like at this massive like
console warning this is a browser
feature in Jennifer developers don't
copy paste stuff in here because
apparently people are copy pasting weird
javascript in here to get more friends
or bit more likes or whatever right but
to me like when we look at this
holistically this is kind of a problem
for the web platform that users of the
web basic hacking himself or feeling
feeling scared right so um we will at
least a blog post the thing was like
yesterday or the day before because in
the edge team we've been looking at our
relatively simple telemetry we have for
its dev tools and this is a graph that
shows that this distribution on on
basically how long how many seconds
people are using our tool and we
basically saw that the majority of our
users of assistive tools are opening the
tools clicking a bit around and then
closing it within 15 seconds and we
basically seen this as an indicator of
people are opening the dips pools by
mistake and because we also can we can
see like if people click inside the tool
and people open it have it open for
maybe six six seconds and then they find
the close button and it closed it again
they're really confused about this thing
and this makes sense when you think
about it because H is right now is
mainly in user browser not a lot of
developers are using it because our
compel compatibility are great but that
basically meant that we looked at this
data and as a part of our last release
we should be a few months ago we've
decided to hide a chip tools by default
so all the developer options like view
souls and inspect element are now hidden
because regular users don't care about
these things they just want to go to
Netflix or go to Facebook and and yet
again we are trying to balance the
balance like the user experience so you
can go to about flags and you can it
like enable it here and say you want to
show you souls in a speculum in the
consequent you click it a new habit
again
like Safari but we also have kept in the
this top shortcut so if you press f12 or
put something that can open the dev
tools to Meereen able the mode again but
we basically like doing this as an
experiment and looking at the data and
then reevaluating it and like I would
love to hear your feedback and turn
stuff like if this is confusing for you
as a developer we basically just trying
to shield and use a much as possible for
these really powerful tools and I just
want to open I don't have like an answer
to this question but why a dev tools
them still bundled with our browsers if
you look at all the change that has
happened to the web is about
applications that the biggest now
running in pwas without any browser
chrome the babe is running inside
electron shells on your desktop
basically the browser chrome the address
bar the refresh button all these things
are now gone and if you look at like the
devices people are the next billion are
going to experience a web app it's going
to be none desktop devices it's going to
be mobile phones it's going to be a new
kind of variables whole lenses kind of
new experiences that doesn't have the
traditional keyboard and mouse and then
yet again we as an industry we insist on
shipping the diff tool use each and
every day to debug or all of these other
devices in a desktop browser and bundle
it at the bottom percent of your screen
for example if you want to debug samsung
internet and i am not aware that samsung
shipping a desktop browsers all right so
maybe we need to take a step back and
enable the dev tools to work out of the
desktop context that maybe work with
some of these new device factors in the
future and really when i think about the
future of diff tools is looking rather
complicated because the future of diff
tools is basically going to be a bunch
of different tools we use microsoft we
will probably continue to ship it stiff
tools will public continues ship Visual
Studio Visual Studio code but what we
imagine is basically world where these
different tools are more integrated
because you as a bit developer you
should have the choice if you want to
use a step to the chrome dev tools
without browser and we already enabled
that and the world is also going to be
that you need you want to have your
favorite editor that could be at them
there could be them or whatever but that
needs to be more integrated with the
runtimes and game developers when we
need to publish their
the games like we cannot force them into
a trip to the chrome dev tools and say
you need to debug your paper simply game
in this bottom of the screen they will
probably prefer to sit inside the editor
where they wrote the code and so we need
to enable all these tools to work with
all the runtimes and we look at the run
time to run times are going to be much
more complicated because as Sam some of
the internet that's UC browser this edge
so far I that's a whole new range of
devices that's probably going to be like
five different variants of electron wave
runtimes you need to check it so these
tools need to be able to work with a
broad set of run times before you as a
developer can be successful and
productive and then if you look at the
basis that that these tools these
browsers or run times are running on
it's going to be a broad range of
devices and if you are sitting here in
Singapore and you need to roll out in
India maybe you need access to devices
Japan up by hand Singapore because they
use a different set of hardware so I
also imagine a future where we have
device clouds where you can say I want
to roll out in Indonesia give me the
five most used devices and then you get
them screencast to you or something like
that we need to solve this because
availability of low-end high-end
hardware is a problem for for all of us
regardless of where we are in the world
so I imagine that you can use s dev
tools to debug safari internet or Sam
some internet and you can add have the
code running on a stream device coming
from the cloud I think this is the
direction we need to go go towards to
enable you as an us as developers to be
much more successful and as the bib
grows out of the browser which is
happening these days as the whole
progressive bit movement we need to
reimagine our dev tools and and at
Microsoft free spending a lot of time
trying to figure this out and as of a
few weeks ago we decided to scale up our
or a stiff tools quite significantly so
if you're interested in trying to help
out and build the future of dip tools
like check out this ul and by that I'm
20 seconds over time so thank you so
much thank you for having me and if
you're interested tag along on Twitter
that's the decibel the future clips all
together thanks
you